MIKE GORDON: Kongregate was
founded by Jim and Emily Greer.
They wanted to create an open
web platform for developers
and indies alike.
They originally called
it the YouTube of games.
My name is my Gordon and I'm
the vice president of publishing
here at Kongregate.
We saw a lot of web developers
making the transition
to mobile, and we saw a need
for a partner like Kongregate
to get into the mobile space.
PETER EYKEMANS:
I'm Peter Eykemans
and I'm a senior producer
here at Kongregate.
Some of our early challenges
when we moved to mobile
were really getting
a grasp on what
players in the mobile
marketplace were looking for.
TAMMY LEVY: We knew what
we were doing on the web
to figure out what players
would like and wouldn't like,
but we didn't really have
those tools on mobile.
So we were really struggling
with figuring out,
how is this going to translate?
I'm Tammy Levy and I'm
the director of product
for mobile games
here at Kongregate.
MIKE GORDON: The Google
Play Developer Console
provides developers with a
ton of really useful tools
in a really accessible manner.
PETER EYKEMANS: We didn't
necessarily have a good way
to distribute builds.
So using the alpha and
beta testing frameworks
within Google Play we were
able to very easily do that.
We can add lists of emails,
groups of people, Google
communities, and rather than
emailing out individual APKs,
we're able to actually
just say, hey,
hit this website
accept tester status
and go download to build.
And that's all we need to do.
TAMMY LEVY: That's how
you do experiments, right?
You don't roll out
something to everyone.
If it's not good, how can
we improve it before we just
push it on everyone else?
PETER EYKEMANS: One of our
first uses of the store listing
experiment was running a
head to head icon test.
One showed an iconic
hero from the game
against a helicopter,
which was one of the units
inside of the game.
Players who were shown
the helicopter icon,
we saw a 92%
increase in downloads
of those users versus the
ones who saw the iconic hero.
So we then moved on
to testing screenshots
where we saw over a 14%
increase in downloads
for the players who were
shown the new variant.
We then moved on to the
text about the game,
where we indicated more
about the strategy,
the types of units players saw.
By testing each of these in
line and we saw increases
across the board.
And when you tally
everything up,
we saw over a 45%
increase in downloads
for players hitting
the new shot.
So it was a very successful
experiment for us.
TAMMY LEVY: We basically
started going crazy
and just applied this
to every single game.
We know that the results
that we're getting
are actually actionable.
And from there put
it all together
and make sure that
we're presenting
the best game possible.
Our advice to all
developers out there
would be to utilize all
the tools in the developer
console to make sure you
set up yourself for success.
MIKE GORDON: There's
a tremendous amount
of information that just lives
in the developer console.
That's accessible by
you at any moment.
It's really easy to use,
really straightforward,
and the information there
is incredibly useful.
PETER EYKEMANS: To
be cliche, you only
get one shot at a
first impression,
so make sure you
test everything,
because you just want to
be sure that the are you
love is the art that your
players are going to love,
and you might not
always be right.